NARRATOR: Hamburg,
Germany, December, 1938.
Four years into Adolf
Hitler's reign as fuhrer,
he is beginning to establish
his total dictatorship
by taking direct control
of the German military.
[speaking german]
[cheering]
But on the brink
of World War II,
Hitler is also involved
in much stranger endeavors
that are hidden to the public.
He is committing every
remaining resource
to searching for ancient
relics that he believes
could hold incredible powers.
On December 17th,
the German freighter
MS Schwabenland sets out on one
of these top secret missions.
Its 33-member team is rumored
to include scientists,
military experts, construction
crews, and key members
of the Thule Society,
an elite group
associated with the
Nazis that focused
on mysticism and the occult.
32 days later, they arrive
at their destination--
Antarctica.
The Nazis themselves
were fascinated
by ancient civilizations
and legends
of vanished super races.
They were searching for
this lost Arctic home
that they thought that
the Aryans had come from.
They were looking
all over the world,
and that included Antarctica.
The Thule Society
actually believed
that there were
mystics or channels who
were able to communicate with
these beings who claim to be
either extraterrestrial
in origin or claim
to belong to this
civilization that
lived in the Earth's interior.
And they gave a
lot of information
about the building of
advanced aerospace vehicles,
flying saucers.
And I think this is where
Hitler's Nazi Party got
a lot of its information
about Antarctica,
and that in Antarctica, there
is this ancient civilization
or bases where they
could find a lot
of these advanced technologies.
NARRATOR: During their
time in Antarctica,
the Nazis were believed
to have mapped huge swaths
of the icy landscape by air.
Ancient astronaut
theorists believe they also
established an elaborate
underground headquarters
known as Base 211.
Hitler and the Nazis were
particularly interested
in Antarctica.
I think they really believed
that there were things
going on deep under the ice.
And there have
always been rumors
that the Nazis, with
their submarines,
have underwater caverns, small
cities, that they escaped
there after World War II.
When the Germans
got to Antarctica,
what they found
were massive cities
that were highly technological.
And these buildings were
not just on the surface.
They went deep down underground.
So they began relocating a
massive amount of equipment
and personnel to
Antarctica, re-pressurizing
these ancient facilities
and reoccupying them.
NARRATOR: In 1946, one year
after the end of World War
II, the US government
launched its own large scale
mission to Antarctica.
Operation High Jump deployed
4,700 troops, 13 ships,
an aircraft carrier, and
a number of sea planes
to Antarctica.
Although the government
denied it at the time,
it would later become known
that one of the operation's
primary objectives was,
quote, extending United States
sovereignty over the
largest practicable area
of the Antarctic continent.